قد تختلف امنيات مسيحيه العراق في اعياد
الميلاد وراس السنه الجديده عن امنيات
المسيحيين في بقيه دول العالم عوده من
هاجر منهم الى ارض الوطن تتصدر هذه
الامنيات غير ان هذه الامنيه مرتبطه بملف
اكبر يتمثل باعاده العقارات التي كان
هؤلاء يمتلكونها وسلبت منهم بعد هجرتهم
الى الخارج سواء بالاستيلاء او بتزوير
الاوراق الرسميه وغيرها كثير من الناس
سلبت بيوتها وهاجرت يعني لولا هذا التسليم
ولولا ماكو امانه كان سافرت طيله السنوات
الماضيه لم تتمكن الجهه الرسميه في العراق
من حسم هذا الملف قبل ان تحيله دائره
واوقاف في المسيحيين الى التيار الصدري
اليوم او بالتزامن مع موسم الاعياد تتمكن
لجنه من التيار من اعاده مجموعه جديده من
هذه العقارات الى اصحابها لتبلغهم بانجاز
اما عبر اتصالات هاتفيه
اللي كان مختصر سابقا
اللي انت وكيل خيريه مو
فاحنا الحمد لله والشكر تم انجازه
ويتم تسليمها
عملت في هذا الاتجاه من عامين وارجعوا
تقريبا 200 عقار او اكثر من 200 عقار هذه
الاعداد من العقارات كانت تحت السيطره
فصائل مسلحه او شخصيات نافذه استغلت هجره
اصحابها الى الخارج لتستولي عليها بالقوه
او التزوير اعاده هذه العقارات الى
اصحابها هي الخطوه الاولى باتجاه عوده
المسيحيين المهاجرين الى العراق او على
الاقل قد تشجعهم على ذلك